if they had spies in my campaign during
my campaign for political purposes that
would be unprecedented in the history of
our country that would be one of the
biggest insults that anyone's ever seen
and it would be very illegal we want to
make sure that there weren't I hope
there weren't frankly president today
talking about the investigation into the
investigate tours and this informant spy
whatever you want to call it and the
reports of it back in 2016 we're back
with the Pam panel Kimberly you've
followed this very closely where is this
all going do you think well most
recently we had the president have a
sit-down obviously with Deputy Attorney
General Rod Rosenstein and FBI director
Christopher ray and say look you need to
cooperate with congressional
investigators get these documents out so
we can say the truth about this
informant or whether there were any more
now look I think there's a lot of people
even in Congress that are still
skeptical that they're gonna get to see
the documents so far the Department of
Justice has only wanted to brief them to
keep tight hold over it and that's going
to be the proof of whether or not the
president's message gets through is are
they allowed to review the material
themselves rather than just go on the
word of Department of Justice officials
here's some lawmakers weighing in on
this whole back and forth and you can
imagine that where they stand
politically is kind of where they stand
on this effort
extraordinary
if this white house is trying to force
our law enforcement and intelligence
communities if such a meeting occurs and
I don't believe it should but if it
occurs it must be bipartisan it is
scheduled to take place on Thursday of
this week the individuals that are
expected to attend our chairman Nunez
chairman Gowdy FBI director Ray DNI
director coats in DOJ official IDO
Callahan so the meeting this Thursday
working strated Chuck by the White House
chief of staff but that's the group
that's going to be there Thursday
ideally they think to get the classified
materials yeah and I am say that the
Chuck Schumer has a point there if this
is about congressional access to these
vital materials why shouldn't it be
bipartisan that I mean they're they're
the Democratic ranking member of that
committee is cleared as well I mean
especially if you don't want to create
the impression that this is just you
know partisanship in the other direction
that there's a real principle at stake
here you know this is a very very
uncharted area the the idea of the
Independence of the intelligence and law
enforcement communities is not written
in the Constitution it's kind of a norm
that's been established since Watergate
really fairly recently in our history
and it's being tested right now we're
gonna find out whether it can withstand
this sort of hyper partisan atmosphere
that we're in and the obvious fury of a
president who comes from outside of that
system and outside of that history at
his belief that this machinery got
turned against him it's not entirely
clear to me that it was being turned
against him at least not an extremely
you know powerful or vicious way the way
he's describing it it sounds like this
halper guy was sort of trying to keep
tabs on carter page late in the summer
that's not exactly embedding a spy in
the campaign
what I say about both sides of the
investigation every time on the panels
we don't know what we don't know Byron
well the the intelligence community and
what Chuck was just talking about they
not only have to to worry about the
print the president's wrath or the
partisan situation on Capitol Hill they
also have to worry about their own
actions this was an election in which
the FBI had both major party can't party
candidates under investigation maybe
they've been too involved in politics
and maybe this is what happens when you
get too involved in politics and as far
as the meeting is concerned we'll see
what happens I mean Republicans have
gotten very wary of these sort of things
by unhappy experience in which they
think that the Justice Department is
going to turn something over and then
they show up in the room and the Justice
Department just wants to talk about
turning something over but in the end
especially if they have the support not
just to the president but especially
House Speaker Paul Ryan if they have
that support they're probably going to
get what they're looking for the last
word here Kimberly wrapped us up as we
you know follow each of these
developments as they come look I think
one problem with those who criticize
this oversight by the house is they
begin from the premise that the
investigators are beyond reproach or
beyond being looked at and given what is
out there already about FISA abuses the
use of a dossier as part of that FISA
warrant who paid for it the rival
campaign that the texts that have gone
back and forth between FBI agents
there's a lot of average Americans that
don't trust those investigators and
that's what's driving this look into it
and the Department of Justice would do
well to get it out there we all have
many more panels something tells me
about this topic